مشهد صعب وسيله خاصه ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يواصل عملياته في انحاء متفرقه من قطاع
غزه الجيش الاسرائيلي يقصف منازل مدنيه
فلسطينيه يقم يقصف خيام النازحين في
المناطق الغربيه لرفح وخانيونس مازال
يحاصر مستشفى ناصر ما زال يحاصر مستشفى
الامل في خانيونس ما زال يقصف في خانيونس
وعملياته مستمره العمليات البريه وعمليات
القصف الاسرائيلي او حتى عمليات القصف
المدفعي بالتالي هي عمليات مستمره في وسط
القطاع في جنوب القطاع في مدينه غزه وفي
رفح وخانيونس بالتالي القصف الاسرائيلي
مستمر لكن ايضا حتى العمليات الاسرائيليه
وجثامين الشهداء التي سرقها الجيش
الاسرائيلي من المقابر في خانيونس وفي
مدينه غزه وفي انحاء متفرقه كان يقتل
السكان المدنيين الفلسطينيين في غزه ومن
ثم يسرق جثثهم وبعد ذلك بعد الفحص و هناك
اطباء يقولون ان اعضاء من اجساد الجث من
اجساد الشهداء الفلسطينيين الذين يسرقهم
الجيش الاسرائيلي هي غير موجوده وبالتالي
حتى الجيش الاسرائيلي والسلطات
الاسرائيليه تسرق هذه الاعضاء قبل قليل
تسلمت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عشرات من
هذه الجسامي من خلال معبر كرم ابو سالم في
اقصى جنوب مدينه رفح جنوب قطاع غزه وجرى
ايصالها الى نقلها الى مستشفى ابو يوسف
النجار حيث سيجري الاطباء الفحص هناك ومن
ثم سيتم تصويرها لانها لان بعضها متحلل
وبالتالي لا يستطيعون التعرف على هذه
الجثامين ومن ثم سيقيمون صلاه الجنازه ومن
ثم سيتم دفنهم في مقابر جماعيه بعد ان تتم
وزاره الصحه هذه الاجراءات هذا بخصوص
الجثامين التي وصلت عبر معبر كرم ابو سالم
اما بخصوص القصف الاسرائيلي فهو متواصل
وربما مدينه خانيونس هي التي تتعرض الى
القصف الاكثر كثافه والقصف الاكثر عنفا
العمليه البريه ما زالت مستمره والجيش
الاسرائيلي ينسف مباني واحياء باكملها في
مدينه مدينه خانيونس خاصه في المناطق
الغربيه لخان يونس منطقه وسط البلد ايضا
في خانيونس تعرضت الى قصف عنيف بعض
المنازل اشتعلت فيها النيران وتصاعدت منها
اعمده الدخان من جراء استمرار المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه لهذا القصف العنيف في تلك
المناطق ايضا مناطق غرب مدينه خانيونس
ومحيط مستشفى ناصر ما زال يتعرض الى ما
زالت تتعرض الى القصف العنيف من المدفعيه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف ايضا من غاراته في
تلك المنطقه منطقه مستشفى حي الامن
او مستشفى الامل مازال السكان النازحون
الذين لجوا الى هذا المركز مركز الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني في حي الامل وايضا
مستشفى الامل في خانيونس مازالوا محاصرين
بسبب تواجد الدبابات الاسرائيليه هناك